كم كم ما هي القوات التي تحمل السلاح داخل
ايران كم جهه تحمل السلاح داخل ايران
رسميا اقصد
سياسي فيه مؤسسات متوازيه وهذه المؤسسات
المتوازيين مثلا في نشاطات الاستخباراتيه
والاهميه والشرطه والجيش
الحرس الثوري والدينا الجيش
الاول للدفاع عن النظام ضد المتظاهرين وفي
نفس الوقت الذي المؤسسات الموازيه
ميليشيات البسيج وهي جزء من الحارس الفوري
والفاره بينها وبين حصري قد يكون سطحيا
ولك مع ذلك تمييز والبس نوعا ما مؤسسه
موازيه لقوات الشرطه
وزاره الاستخبارات
في قمع المتظاهرين وفي نفس الوقت ايضا
لدينا منظمه استخبارات الحرس الثوري
والغرض من كلها اللي هي المؤسسات
المتوازيه هي لتحسين النظام الانقلاب اي
لا يوجد مركز واحد السلطه الكامل علقه
النظريه ولكن في الحقيقه فان الحرس الثوري
باقه قويا الى الاحد الذي ما عدا هناك
توازن بينه وبين المؤسسات الاخرى ولكن
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه فيها المؤسسات
المتوازيه وهذه المؤسسات
تضعفه
المؤسسات الفرديه وفي نفس الوقت من
الانقلاب وهذا هو الغرض منها النظام يدفع
التكلفه تحصين نفسه من الانقلابات